oh hey after the wild success of the
lego movie Warner Brothers was searching
for a new breakout Universal superstar
so of course they went straight to me
simply what they recut it to make it
about my son la Lloyd yes dad and it's
Lloyd so what's this movie about well
it's the story of a regular kid from
Ninjago whose dad happens to be an evil
warlord and my secret identity as the
green ninja the leader of the secret
ninja force hit it
earth ninja fire ninja water ninja
lightning ninja ice ninja 3 ninja but
saved in jogo
starring in a movie with your friends is
the best
although Kai did go a little crazy he
started eating like the rock two pounds
of baked crab every two hours and no
gluten
hey bro didn't see you there I'm just
kidding I totally saw you there I'm a
ninja I see everything I'm Kai did you
see my Mac it's on fire not cool sis I'm
Nia the strongest ninja in the crew
little-known facts about me warner
brothers originally wanted me for Wonder
Woman Yeah right they did we ran into
scheduling issues bro hi I'm sane I'm
playing a robot human teenager in this
film I just downloaded all the newest
coolest music the kids are listening to
to my hard drive I'm digging that funky
tuned Esposito dab me outside
hey I'm Cole hey look give me a favor if
you talk to the producers can you
mention using my beats on the soundtrack
let's rock
they are killer and I'm J
I'm the confident one in the group what
is that afraid of anything
ah near being a ninja is not all fun and
games practice spin Jitsu
that's easy watch this exercise for
three hours you've got to be ready for
Garmadon to attack at any time
oh come on the Lord loves his old man
hello what do you want you called me
okay you know what that was taken
completely out of context and family is
deeply important to me just ask my weird
brother Wu
Garmadon I sense the presence of a foe
you know what I see what you're doing
here this whole thing is just made to
make me look like the bad guy
classic headpiece yes I'm out of here on
PBS you're all fired
oh yeah co-starring in a big movie is
fun but you know if you ask me my
favorite role is being lights mom it's
great being able to work together as a
family even uncle will love the Lego
movies you needed unlike anything I'm a
fanboy the Lord I have something very
important to ask you do you want to play
catch with your old man
you came back to Ninjago to play catch
with me I sure did son and also to
conquer the city
[Music]
the fate of Ninjago is in your hands are
you ready yes
maybe cue the music
here we go the lego ninjago Google on
September 22nd Ninjago hey mom can we
talk about dad
so when you guys got together was dad
always an evil okay well here it is
he had so many plans you swim vicious he
said he wanted to conquer the world I
thought it was a figure of speech but if
I had never met Garmadon I would have
never had you
[Applause]
[Music]
the spear students are tuning your nose
and when to fight and when to plant in
the shadows
unbelievable garbage
you can't catch me green ninja watch
this
come from hello dad the Lloyd that's
right and it's Lloyd
dad it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect yeah but I feel like there's
more to Garmadon that I need to know to
understand your future you must go back
to your ninja roots your dad was a ninja
- Lloyd you hear that we don't waken the
unstoppable beast
the Alfa are you ready to risk your life
for Ninjago ninja
I haven't felt this good in a long time
no noise okay yeah yeah I think I think
it's my arm is it bad if I want to look
the scale of one to ten to help that is
it oh I'd say it's about a seven point
arm ripped off this film is not yet
rated
[Music]